how's it going everybody warned here and
if you haven't seen Aquaman I highly
recommend you do it was a great movie I
was actually really impressed and I'll
do a breakdown and a review on it later
on but for now I want to talk about the
post-credits scene
DC normally doesn't have post-credit
scenes in their movies so this is kind
of a treat for us also if you have not
seen Aquaman there are some spoilers in
this video so here's your official
warning so the post-credits scene starts
off with doctor shin finding Black Manta
adrift at sea the last time we saw Black
Manta was in Italy when he was fighting
Aquaman he was equipped with some very
new and very powerful an Atlantean
technology so he gave Aquaman a run for
his money ultimately Aquaman ended up
defeating him by throwing two stones
attached to a chain at Black Manta
causing him to essentially blow himself
up with his optic blast this caused him
to fall off the cliff
and into the water and then you think
he's dead until the post-credits scene
doctor shin finds him adrift at sea and
takes him back to his home doctor shin
is a character who you see throughout
the movie and he's a marine biologist
who believes in Atlantis during the
movie he tries to convince people that
Atlanteans exist and in the post-credits
scene you can see him on the TV talking
about how all of these recent anomalies
in the world and on the ocean are caused
by Atlanteans so dr. Shin is tinkering
with black mantas technology when Black
Manta wakes up doctor shin accidentally
causes black mantas helmet to fire an
optic beam Ethan looks at Black Manta
and says this is aunt lani and
technology isn't it
can you tell me where you got this Black
Manta then says sure but first you got
to tell me how to find him he then
throws his knife at a article that says
who is Aquaman so you have dr. Shin who
is obsessed with finding Atlantis and
then you have Black Manta who is
obsessed with Aquaman so he can find him
and kill him for revenge
basically this post-credit scene is
setting up for Black Manta to be
Aquaman's main villain and black manta
and dr. Shin are going to team up
because it'll be mutually beneficial for
the both of them Black Manta will be
able to find Aquaman and attempt to kill
him and dr. Shin will get a little bit
more information about a plane
and he'll get to tinker around with some
Atlantean technology so they'll both get
something good out of it in the comics
dr. shin is actually friends with Arthur
and he knows that he's Aquaman but their
friendship sort of drifts apart when dr.
shim becomes a little too obsessed with
finding Atlantis so it seems like in the
movie the character is taking a little
bit of a different turn yes he's still
obsessed with finding Atlantis but he's
not friends with Arthur in the movie so
there you have it the post-credits scene
for Aquaman setting up Black Manta to be
Aquaman's main villain in the future
movies let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below and if
you have seen Aquaman let me know what
you thought about it I'm also giving
away a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet if
you would like to enter for your chance
to win all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]